sans donner ni calendrier ni date
bruxelles incite les européens à rouvrir
progressivement les frontières
intérieures
les citoyens des pays baltes estonie
lituanie et lettonie pourront à partir
de ce vendredi voyager sans limite entre
les trois pays
un déverrouillage est également
envisagée avec la finlande et la pologne
la suisse la slovénie le portugal et la
hongrie commence de leur côté à baisser
doucement lagarde en autorisant les
passages de frontières pour motifs
professionnels et familiaux
l'autriche et l'allemagne vont rouvrir
leur frontière dès le 15 juin prochain
on le voit donc chacun y va à son rythme
et selon sa propre formule et c'est ce
que bruxelles
il ne veut pas entendre du coup
l'exécutif européen propose un retour à
la normale en trois étapes dans un
document que s'est procuré life paix et
dans la face une du plan proposé par
bruxelles on parle d'une levée
progressive et réciproque des contrôles
entre états voisins mais les européens
vont devoir s'aligner se coordonner et
communiquer entre eux par exemple
l'autriche et l'allemagne qui ont donc
décidé de la réouverture de leur
frontière mi juin doivent aussi le faire
avec d'autres voisins dans une situation
sanitaire comparables de même quand on
est à ouvrir ses frontières avec un
autre pays il doit le faire pour tous
les habitants qu'ils aient la
nationalité ou non la phase 2
permettrait ensuite d'aboutir à une
levée partielle des contrôles dans
l'ensemble de l'espace schengen c'est
lors de cette phase que se poseraient
notamment la question des voyages
touristiques
la commission européenne préconise pour
cette phase des mesures de sécurité
sanitaire dans les transports et les
infrastructures touristiques
et puis il ya la phase iii beaucoup plus
lointaine qui permettrait d'arriver un
retour à la normale pour les 27
il faut dire que la liberté de mouvement
au sein de l'espace schengen est
cruciale pour le tourisme européen
un secteur qui représente 10% du pib de
lieux et 12 % de l'emploi
enfin dans ce document la commission
aborde la délicate question du
remboursement ou non des voyages et
séjours annulés selon la réglementation
de l'ue eux le consommateur européen est
en droit de réclamer un remboursement
problème bon nombre d'opérateurs et de
compagnies aériennes
et faire proposer un avoir à leurs
clients pour bruxelles les transporteurs
et les voyagistes devraient suivre une
approche commune il pourrait offrir aux
voyageurs le choix entre un
remboursement en espèces conformément
aux droits que leur confère la
législation européenne ou l'acceptation
d'un bond des changes